hey theo this is will i called about a
year ago
my daughter eliana was born oh man
congratulations on that one year old you
got now man
that's a beautiful treat man my buddy
just had a kid
about maybe nine weeks ago or something
and he sent me a picture of it and it
looked like a damn little ghost
little scared little fella but still
beautiful man amen let's hear it
appreciate that by the way let me on the
show
i just wanted to kind of ask your
thoughts about
the crystal leah situation because i
heard you and bobby talking about that
last week and i was thinking to myself
if one of my buddies got some deep stuff
some trouble
and he said like hey i didn't do that
that wasn't me like i'd want to back
obviously the the crystalia situation is
pretty
deep deeper than that um
but i mean you even said like
like people were mad about him talking
to a 22 year old
so like maybe it's not as bad as it
cracked up to be i don't know much about
it to be honest that's not the base
facts so i don't know man do you ever
feel bad about
not backing him like
well i appreciate your question man um i
mean there's
there's you know and yeah me and bobby
were talking about this the other day on
uh
on the episode and i think
i i i back chris you know like i check
in with him
you know i probably should check in with
him again um
you know chris doesn't communicate a ton
with me
we never have communicated like a great
deal like
our friendship you know we haven't had
like a deep deep friendship
um i think he's one of the funniest guys
that i know
i don't so i don't know the extent of
everything that's going on either
you know i don't know the extent do i
believe everything that's
that do i believe that the articles that
people have written like a lot of it
seems like hit pieces to me
you know but also i don't know
everything about it
you know i i feel like um
it's really tough you know because
people do everything now for click
bait it's really tough
um but i do know that i
you know
that it's tough for a lot of his friends
and a lot of his associates
and co-workers to know what to say or do
because he hasn't really said much
so i think in a weird way we're all kind
of waiting
not waiting to hear from him i mean and
he did say his piece there was an
article he
that he had or that was about like his
side of the story and his thoughts on it
and
um you know i don't know i don't know if
there's like legal stuff that he's
facing i don't know
and some of it it's interesting because
it's like it's not my
you know like um it's not my
responsibility to
or it's not it's none of my business to
bother him to bother him about any of
that
you know i check in and say you know you
know how are you doing
you know thinking of you um
i don't look at i mean the media often
looks at people as one dimensional
oh they're just this or that's how it
seems a lot of times
um but i mean i support you know i
support my friends as much as i
you know i love him
you know i want him to be able to work
um i'm grateful that he has a family
right now that he has a wife and kid and
he has people that are close to him to
support him
and people to keep him hopeful and
excited
um
you know i don't know i don't know what
a lot of his behaviors were
like really no you know i don't know
i don't go you know i
so it's like
you know yeah you i have their back i
have my friends back i mean
a lot of everything we do you you don't
see it on podcast you don't always hear
about it
um there's also a lot of like a lot of
guys are afraid and a lot of people are
afraid i think just of
you know of a lot of just you know
are they going to be written an article
about next even if some of the stuff it
doesn't even
have any validity
um you know it's scary
it makes me feel uncomf it makes me feel
scared to even talk about like i have to
watch my words
um
[Music]
because there's people out there that
want to take people's livelihood away
but then also if people did something
that is illegal
then i feel like that they should be
held accountable for it
but also i don't feel like people that
if they did something illegal that that
damns them as a someone that i could
should care about
or that there's not more to them as a
person
i mean dude we're all like just messed
up creatures trying to freaking
balance right between the sand and and
the and the water
so
you know it's tricky out there
it's tricky out there it's tricky in
here tricky inside of ourselves man it's
tricky everywhere but
when people say you didn't back him what
is backing someone look like i mean
i've let him know that i love him i've
let him know that
you know i'm here for him i've let him
know that if he feels like he has an
issue or
with anything that he's welcome to you
know i go to different meetings for all
types of stuff
so he's welcome to come with me anytime
he wants to
or but i appreciate
the reminder may you know maybe i should
check in with him again and just you
know remind him
that people think about him you know
that people care about him you know i
texted callum the other day and told him
you know
to keep his head up
um just as i would text any of my
friends or
communicate any with any of my friends
who if something bad happened to them
you know just as i'm sure like the
accusers
are or the victims of of the alleged
incidents or their friends are
supporting them
you know it's i don't know
i'm just human man i i don't know good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one